what next for Boris Johnson no smiles as
he approaches the end of his first big
summit as p.m. but he's probably feeling
pretty happy with himself Boris Johnson
has performed a delicate political dance
in which both the US and EU seem his
natural partners reassuring the
Europeans that on policy be that Iran
climate change trade Wars he's with them
and hopeful that he's gone some way this
past week to persuade European leaders
to remove obstacles around a revised
brexit deal but it's his progress with
this man that will really delight mr.
Johnson you've met our new prime
minister Boris Johnson yesterday yes you
said he was the right man for the job on
trucks it I believe there do you think
Theresa May was the wrong woman and do
you think that Boris Johnson can
actually get a deal with the EU before
October the 31st she chose to do it her
way and that didn't work out so well I
think she's a very very good person and
a good woman and I really believe that
Boris Johnson will be a great prime
minister you know we like each other
and we had a great two and a half days
I've been waiting for him to be Prime
Minister for about six years I told him
what took you so long a glowing
endorsement from the president mr.
Johnson feeling on top of the world with
every conversation that I've had with my
fellow leaders I've been struck by their
enthusiasm to expand and strengthen
their relations with our country but he
still has a big problem to solve mr.
Johnson you talk about what MPs should
do but there is going to be whether you
like it or not a parliamentary roadblock
on your No Deal brexit when you returned
to Westminster if enemies pass or not
requiring you to extend article 15 what
will you do we suspect Parliament or you
call an election I think that it's the
job of everybody in parlor
to get this thing done I think it's what
the people want I also think by the way
it's what our friends and partners on
the other side of the channel what they
want they want this thing done they want
they want it over there are big big
opportunities for this country so I
think we need a new way of thinking
about it but first of all you've got to
come out as you know on October the 31st
a classic brexit dodge but this is a
question that will have to be answered
before too long mr. Johnson will leave
this summit feeling it's been a job well
done
he couldn't have hoped for better
rapport with President Trump and with
his European allies he managed to avoid
a brexit blow-up but while he's still
talking tough on a No Deal exit from the
EU behind the scenes I'm hearing about a
very different Prime Minister one who is
keen to impress upon his European allies
that he's really serious about trying to
get a deal a good summit but his guard
will be up as he leaves these shores
back home he faces another very
difficult perhaps impossible negotiation
with Parliament over his brexit position
in the saddle for now but he'll have to
tread very carefully indeed bathra be
Sky News bereit